hey guys welcome back to bring your V to
Rebecca on for night so we're gonna be
doing something a little bit different
Thank You Ubisoft for sponsoring this
video but we'll cook some quick Tippit's
of information foreigner is not gonna be
50% off so if you don't have the game
currently or you know a friend that
wants it definitely show them this video
it is 50% off and as well there's going
to be a hero trial available from
February 5th to the 12th you'll
basically be able to test out all the
new woodland heroes as if you've
unlocked them in the game for free for
just that entire week to get a little
bit of a feel maybe you'll end up buying
the marching for expansion because of it
stuff like that it's very exciting stuff
foreigners been doing this a lot for the
past couple years on the DLC character
so this is no different so definitely if
you do not have the marching fire
expansion you can definitely go get the
Wulin heroes or if you're still on the
fence then you can obviously test out
the hero trials and see what character
fits for your play style on top of that
there's also new mask outfits that were
recently released for the new Wulin
characters because of the Chinese New
Year so now you can rock the I believe
these y'all bow which is personally one
of my favorite woven masks one of the
two of that they have and now you can
unlock that for grandpa
stick boy girl that looks like she got
her swords from hammer felt and this
thing but with that I wanted to showcase
some of the mask outfits and stuff in
arcade is so I thought I'd do a little
bit of a challenge showing off the high
tier gear with no gear stats while I try
to talk about arcade mode and what it
entails are you serious this is torture
okay so maybe that didn't work send up
picking up a buddy named Talon Dillard
and another amazing foreigner content
creator who makes great gameplay videos
is a very highly skilled player so if
you want to see some top tier gameplay
definite go check out his channel he's
very good at what he does in the game
and he's the results that we got from
that yo good morning I'll take the
warden try to try to get both be glad oh
my god the zone
I'm dead Wow 372 for a top-heavy I
thought it was a light we're gonna have
to play this he'll a different truth I
agree
[ __ ] dude I did it again 372 toaster was
not you know I feel like it's doable if
we just don't know if it's doable if we
don't die immediately and as you can
tell we are back to square one we didn't
even beat the first mission this
challenge was really stupid but that's
why the video in the title says attempt
is because clearly we didn't beat it so
stop me from spiking my monitor and
throwing it across the room I decided to
just have some gameplay of the regular
arcade while I talk about what arcade
entails
if you're not aware what arcade was it
was released during marching fire and it
comes to the marching fire expansion
which like I said before is half off so
definitely want to grab that it is a PvE
experience both solo and with a friend
this game one has different modifiers
ranging from more damage less damage
full bars of bleed revenge instantly and
tons more making the experience harder
or easier depending on your luck now you
can play multiple different types of
quests ranging from very low gear stats
like what is in the gameplay now or a
very high gear stats if you have a
higher character or as you can tell from
the beginning playing low gear stats and
a high gear stats quest which I totally
do not recommend and like I said these
aren't your regular duels that come with
modifiers and the modifiers are
different every single time you can hop
into a game with a set of quests leave
the game and then come back to that same
exact tab and it'll be an entirely new
set of challenges two sets of enemies
and modifiers to make the entire thing
completely different and it's like
you're experiencing something brand new
for the first time every single time you
hop on to it so it's a really fun game
mode and it's also a really nice change
of the flow to the game if you want to
take a break from ranking up your
characters constantly you can hop in
arcade and do that as well and also even
if you're sick of playing multiplayer
you can actually hop in our cave mode
and still rank up your characters that
way so you won't be losing your rapper
you won't be losing out on match time
because you can still rank up your
character during arcade which is really
nice and you can get some new type of
effects that come with it such as the
pink plasma shock any crimson conquest
which are really cool effects that I've
done videos on so you can definitely
check those out as well they're really
nice effects that are only unlocked
through our cave they
it's gonna be the end of the VTA
hopefully guys did enjoy it like I said
thank you be soft for sponsoring the
video hope you guys did enjoy my
horrible and mediocre attempt at trying
a challenge that is stupid difficult but
I kind of want to throw this off to you
guys I definitely try to challenge you
guys to do this yourselves like I said I
tried as you could tell from the video I
tried this alone then I tried it with a
teammate and it's still equally as hard
if you guys want to try this and you do
complete it definitely send it to me on
discord or Twitter the links to those
will be in the description I'd love to
see your completed runs cuz this [ __ ] is
way too hard for me to attempt we like
to V if you do enjoy subscribe if you're
new I cover the informational side of
foreigner and that being balanced
changes here updates patch notes and
leaks with that guy so have a great
yesterday thanks for watching the video
and peace out definitely go cop marching
fire if you haven't already and tell
your friends
deuces guys
[Music]